Bob curry who served with the same SAS
unit as myself hit the headlines last
week when it was revealed he was
homeless and he referred council would
reportedly failed to house him I'm sure
Bob will be looked after thanks to
support from celebrities the public and
the regiment he's lucky to have a cap
badge that gets the media's attention my
concern however is the vets who fall on
hard times and go and hurt I'm nearly
come unstuck
more than once myself ex servicemen and
women are proud and hold back before
asking for help but there are plenty of
others who exploit the benefit system
while those who deserve help but hung
out to dry no one who serves their
country should ever be left in the lurch
or anywhere near the back of the housing
queue I'd like to see veterans from all
of our frontline services police
firefighters and nurses given priority
when they fall in the hard times it's
not that others should be shelved but
those who serve to keep us all safe at
night should be looked after first at
the comments I thought I would find
universal sympathy for him and I didn't
I found some hideous comments from
people who who clearly have no idea what
him and people like yourself accepts
that I have done you've seen done things
that none of us can envisage in our
worst nightmares and and I found I found
there was there was not the kind of
sympathy out there that I thought there
would be and and then I started to do
some reading into this and it turns out
that this government doesn't keep a
record of the number of homeless
ex-servicemen we have they care so
little about them there is no official
in the British Legion which is set out
to help exertion they don't know leaves
Griffin homeless charities put together
a list of a few months ago and they said
that there are 7,000 ex-servicemen
living rough an Austrian why not just
let me can I just remind everybody what
Bob actually did and the level of
commitment that you was prepared to show
in the good and benefit of everybody in
this country let's have a quick which is
here we go there on the balcony they go
this is Iranian embassy so you naughty
lady there you go okay the embassy had
been taken over by bad guys so what the
perv are gonna break it right down the
people and
they were holding hostages and a team of
SAS went in and basically rescue the
hostages and engage with the enemy right
like you do
and Bob's nickname in that he was called
backdoor Bob he he saw an unexploded
explosive ran out had kicked it out the
way and smashed through a windy was the
first man inside that so which was
pretty incredible thing to do and
there's a thing called the Armed Forces
and Community Covenant I know you're
gonna say something about this this was
in 2012 and every local authority in the
country was asked to sign up to this and
the deal was you had to you had to they
had to promise to give affordable
housing to give priority to
ex-servicemen fear for that I just made
that bias by its very nature will never
I'm gonna give you a finger in a moment
for one thing we can help hang our hat
on which is how many veterans there are
in this country and I think that figure
might surprise a bit by its very nature
we'll never know the exact number of
them but let's take a look at a
statistic that we can all sign up to
which is 2.5 million UK Armed Forces
veterans in Great Britain know that
officially doesn't mean that homeless is
is a percentage they're off that is but
what I found truly astonishing about the
story about your former SAS colleague is
that it was reported that the only
person who survived the only terrorist
who survived was a he got a life term
which of us doesn't mean a life term in
Britain anymore and he's now out and it
is reported that he's enjoying council
accommodation in South London but when
challenged you just quit you'd listen
you'd have to be stark raving mad or
after Hersh not to agree with what you
just said
I'm only kidding I'm only kidding as
regards veterans but Phil nurses long
hard hours for the benefit of other
people until recently a police officer
could retire off to 40 years with not
anymore
but with full salary pension it doesn't
exist anymore but it used to exist until
some years ago so a bloke or woman goes
in does 40 40 years comes out maybe it's
not even maybe is not even 50 about 50
whatever he might be v limit fifties so
you can go and do something else do
another business and we're sponding him
or her full salary you would need a
pension put someone the reader two and a
half million pounds to enjoy that and
that's what we have been giving I repeat
now so you've got to look at the
economics that takes money twists and
turns and let's not forget there's two
and a half million bits not all of them
in desperate trouble okay and we don't
know the figure for the ones that are so
what I'm saying is nobody I wouldn't
leave one behind and about the ones in
the Armed Forces cover let's just have a
look at the precise wording of that this
is what we as a country again and I'm
sure sure so let's have a look at that
those are served in the Armed Forces
where the regular or Reserve those who
have served in the past and their family
should face no disadvantage compared to
other citizens in the provision of
public and commercial services special
consideration is appropriate in some
cases especially for those who have
given most such as the injured and the
brief what I do think fear is in you
know having an American wife I travel a
lot to the US and I see the difference
in culture with a way in which US
veterans are meted and greeted and they
are often told thank you for your
service and I don't think that
culturally we do enough as a country in
that way so I don't know how often
you've been told just by passers-by
thank you for your service but I think
that it's a it's a touch which though a
gesture I think points to a wider shift
in culture that I think needs to happen
in the way that we generally as a
society see I think if we plot pollinate
you know I mean we do everything else
for the Americans you know we got the
war with them we'd do everything else
with them where we don't cross-pollinate
is on it is on our veteran aftercare
okay and we could learn a lot for the
Americans for sure well there's this
covenant here this covenant for I think
was 407 local authorities signed up to
it and you know what that even made
they've now because they've signed up
and they're obliged to give housing to
ex-servicemen they've now handed it to
housing associations which don't have
the obligation to do that and even and
they're even trying to diddle your
people out of homes biased by say
because there's a loophole
instead of saying should be governor
says should be given an advantage over
affordable housing because it doesn't
say must be they're not actually these
things I promise with one end and take
away with the other I kind of write a
reply to the council involved football
query which is Herefords Herefordshire
Council and they say our commitment to
the Armed Forces covenant which we were
just talking about me
we prioritize housing for former members
of the services and they're given an
advantage on the waiting list
mr. curry has been on the social housing
like social housing waiting list since
we met with him and he has placed a bid
on a property but what I I agree with
everything that's been said I agree I
think it's a disgrace that we ask people
to risk their lives in service and then
we treat them like this and we were
having a debate just a few weeks ago
about the problems with the Armed Forces
recruiting new new service men and women
well it's not surprising if you know
you're a young person you think you're
going to end up on the streets having
risked your life why would you sign up I
completely agree with what you're saying
the only thing I would add is that I
don't see this as a zero-sum game as
then I don't think we should be choosing
between housing our servicemen and women
and a housing other public sector works
or housing families I I can see why
you're saying that the reality is right
we have seen a 73% increase in
homelessness in this country in three
years it is a dire situation there are
so many people that I think we could all
agree in a civilized country we do not
want to see reduce the living on the
streets or in hostels or in houma shells
including 120,000 children so I agree
with what you're saying I agree that
there are people who've made unique
sacrifice should be looked after but I'm
not comfortable the idea that if we
solve that problem we can rest easy
because there are so many people I'll
just point out you have improved in the
board the Armed Forces covenant came in
at 2012 what Bob probably got out in
about 87 or someone that you know I mean
so it doesn't feel too down either and
not to say and I mentioned the early
forces guys are proud of what they did
and don't often stand up for themselves
and so when this information is just
given to local councils they're not
busting your door to have to give it to
you how they turn out I mean they're not
helping out so this stuff isn't getting
fluent it's proven it's not getting from
the fact about the failure of successful
governments to build council housing and
also losing their stock and now relying
on housing associations because as you
were saying then there's so much less
control